[Música]
Olá meu nome é lebre eu tenho dez
anos e eu sou do quarto
Excelente
hoje eu vou clou-los para vocês
sustentabilidade deve contar uma ganância
mas por que você em um
menina de dez anos acredita porque eu
sou o futuro e ele tem
responsabilidade de todas as crianças incluídas
para garantir meu futuro
uma das alternativas é na verdade
para transformar energia
isso significa que você é sustentável, mas isso
é sustentável sustentável que nós
hoje e amanhã os pés na terra fazem
uma questão urgente e necessária
mas no sábado na ciência
informado
foi quando ele aprendeu que tinha muita energia
à energia sonora à energia luminosa
e que contanto que a energia que você
não é bom para o meio ambiente e prejudicá-los
as datas definidas mostram que o
não desenvolva novas construções como o petróleo
carvão e gás natural se a loja for
o que há além da natureza eles estão lá
deve o sol ter tido esse sofrimento e
pode transformar o desempenho letão
sol é um e energia é um
energia renovável e eficiente
um dia ele tem energia para safina
visto que nós humanos podemos fazer muito
beneficiar do sol
e por isso foi torturado
botão inventado, mas quem o fez
botão fotovoltaico inventou este
incluindo os físicos alessandro e
cobiça os registros do modo padrão
inventou
no antigo 199 mas no botão fotovoltaico
muitos dos pratos são assados ​​no local
facada finlandesa
levou o copo para o departamento completo
uma célula fotovoltaica no exterior
uma mão é feita um departamento
acima de tudo uma diversão e uma conexão
box águas fotovoltaicas nos deu isso
palavra foto não encontra e procurada a partir disso
tem madeira fotovoltaica então
longo caminho para ficar procurado holt
para isso e uma bateria fotovoltaica
bateria consola energia em eletricidade quando você
abaixe também aqueça a água
os leitores têm nós temos o post e
contras postar uma caixa de energia limpa
mais novo em energia uma energia e
desperdiçar um e energia e energia para
baixo fora do alcance do usuário final
bússola é uma dependência do
rede que não alimenta a bateria
prejudica o meio ambiente altos custos iniciais
lugares ensolarados e desenvolvimento de
tecnologia e pesquisa
estar sentado agora
para que você acha que é esse número
os homens sim e carregá-lo a qualquer momento
carros importados e onde as mulheres sim
acredite em deus ou este valor alguns
marcas são retas agora eu tenho um
pergunta o que mais posso fazer
minha escola tanto mais no conhecimento
crítica anna-lisa aldinger o suficiente de
dar ao meu território fazendo isso
gosto significa que a energia tem eletricidade
energia termica
o acordo é de 50 e 95 por cento
dentro neste preço este preço em
a lei letã antes da escola e
a velha manteiga sakkos eu quero essa
torná-lo um pouco longo por causa disso
Eu quero provar energia média
o lekker aqueceu a energia
Hoje eu percebo o quão importante é este
projeto aqui para você mostrar
velho ditado diz que você não é um pescador
significa que a preocupação e a
Resultado de incerteza sobre a cabeça
envergonhado, mas você não tem que deixá-lo
que é capaz de vazar dinheiro
Muito obrigado
[Aplausos]